so one of the hardest things when you
are starting as an entrepreneur when
you're trying to start some type of
anything whether it's a business or
nonprofit or an organization is you're
going to want to share your idea and
what you're working on with a lot of
folks and you're going to get different
reactions and it's not unlikely that
you're going to get a lot of folks who
will tell you things like well this is
already done before why do you think
you're going to be able to do it or this
has never been done before why do you
think we're going to be able to do it
and it's very hard to to to judge
whether ok are they just being naysayers
and just being negative and I should
just power through it or should I listen
seriously to what they have to say and
like all things take this all with a
grain of salt it's hard to know for sure
but I like to think about whether people
are coming from a point of view of that
they really want you to succeed and if
there are people in your life that you
know at the end of the day have got your
back and really want you to succeed I
would listen to what they're saying now
it doesn't mean what they're saying is
absolutely true it's completely possible
that they might have a different
tolerance for risk than you do
but it's worth processing it's worth at
least listening and sometimes when
people say oh well this has been tried
before why do you think you doing it is
going to work well the answer to that is
sometimes how you do it matters a lot
more than the idea itself Khan Academy
is an example of that I wasn't the first
person to think that online could be a
way to disseminate information I wasn't
the first person to think that software
could personalize education for folks I
wasn't the first person to make content
on YouTube or to help teach people
through through video but there was
something about how it all came together
and also the time and space and and how
accessible was that things caught on and
that would have been very hard to
predict
had I not at least tried and the way
that I protected myself from both the
positive and negative positive and
negative feedback was I told myself you
know what this is all good information
I'm going to listen to what people have
to say but I'm also going to try it and
I'm going to try it in a way that I can
start to learn
what is actually working and what's not
working and you know if you can work on
your day job so to speak while you start
to fiddle and you can start to build
those data points and points of
confirmation that you might be on to
something well you know then it makes
you a little bit more resilient to what
folks might tell you and you should keep
listening
but you shouldn't arrest everything on
unnecessarily what what everyone tells
you